hasta ahorita todas las moléculas a las
que les hemos puesto el nombre son
alcanos en este vídeo vamos a expandir
nuestro repertorio ahora poniendo los
nombres a los al que nos y bueno puse
todos estos hidrógenos por aquí en esta
cadena de carbonos para recordarte a qué
nos referimos cuando ponemos simplemente
estas líneas que representan el
esqueleto de la cadena y bueno también
aquí ya tenemos un enlace doble como te
puedes imaginar cuando tenemos ya
enlaces dobles tenemos una estructura
mucho más rígida por ejemplo aquí entre
estos dos carbonos ya no hay una
rotación libre y por eso todos estos
hidrógenos y todas estas cosas que
componen a la cadena empiecen a ser más
importantes ya no es una cadena
simétrica pero no pienses mucho al
respecto ahorita lo único que vamos a
hacer es nombrar esta molécula ok
entonces buscamos la cadena de carbonos
más larga que conforme a esta molécula y
bueno resulta que en esta molécula
tenemos una sola cadena de carbono
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 carbonos por lo tanto
estamos lidiando con un ept mccray de
que tiene 7 carbonos sin embargo esta
molécula no es un ept ano ok porque está
no significaría que esta molécula es un
arcano y los arcanos tienen únicamente
enlaces simples sin embargo aquí tenemos
un enlace doble lo cual nos está
diciendo que en realidad estamos
lidiando con un al que no al que no o
que no al canon sino al que no y esta
terminación no significa que hay por lo
menos un enlace doble y bueno si hubiera
un enlace triple entonces sería un al
'chino' pero todavía no vamos a hablar
de esos mientras tanto aquí en el nombre
vamos a poner una terminación en lo que
nos está diciendo que esta molécula es
un al que no y que tiene por lo menos un
enlace doble
aquí todavía no estamos diciendo en
donde está el enlace doble ahora para
decir dónde está el enlace doble lo
hacemos igual que cuando tenemos un
grupo alquiló porque como cuando tenemos
otra sub cadena de carbonos en alguno de
estos carbonos lo que hacemos es empezar
a enumerar los carbonos de la cadena por
el extremo más cercano a nuestro enlace
doble que en este caso es por acá
entonces este es el carbono 1 que este
es el carbono 2 3
4 5 6 y 7 y el enlace doble se encuentra
entre el carbono gas y el carbón o 3 y
para tener una localización específica y
concreta entonces tomamos el número más
pequeño entre los cuales está el doble
enlace y usamos ese nombre y lo ponemos
aquí en medio tenemos el guión 2 jong
enoh y eso lo que significa es que
tenemos una cadena de 7 carbonos con un
doble enlace en el segundo carbono ok
esta terminación en no significa que
tenemos un doble enlace
y colocamos aquí en medio todos los
lugares donde empiezan los dobles
enlaces y la terminación en no significa
que hay un doble enlace
la fe ahora para ver cómo se escribe si
tenemos más de un enlace doble pues
vamos a ver otro ejemplo
vamos a poner otra cadena de carbonos
por aquí
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 carbonos entonces
también va a ser un es algo y vamos a
decir que tiene un doble enlace por aquí
por acá entonces lo que hacemos es
empezar a enumerar los carbonos desde el
extremo más cercano a algún enlace doble
entonces este es el carbono 1 2 y el 3 4
5 6 y 7 y como tiene por lo menos un
enlace doble y ninguno triple entonces
estamos lidiando con un al que no que
lleva la terminación no y ahora nos
fijamos en dónde están los enlaces
dobles aquí tenemos un enlace doble que
va del carbono 2 al carbono 3 por lo que
tenemos que poner aquí que hay un enlace
doble en el carbono 2
así es que ponemos guión 2 y después una
coma para poner ahora donde se encuentra
el otro enlace doble aquí tenemos el
otro enlace doble que va del carbono 4
al carbono 5 entonces tenemos que poner
por aquí el carbono más chico asociado a
este enlace que es el carbono
y el yen ok eps 241 eps de que tiene 7
carbonos y después el no de que tiene
enlaces dobles en los carbonos 2 y 4
siempre la terminación en no está
relacionada con los enlaces dobles esta
es la forma correcta de nombrar a esta
molécula sin embargo hay otras personas
que prefieren poner estos números al
inicio de la palabra seguramente es
porque es más fácil de pronunciar y
entonces por ejemplo a esta molécula le
llaman 2 opte no
no ya esta molécula le llaman 24
y si es mucho más fácil de pronunciar
sin embargo esta es la forma correcta de
llamarle porque la terminación en no
está relacionada con el doble enlace y
aquí estamos diciendo que hay un doble
enlace en los carbonos 2 y 4 ahora
hagamos más ejemplos
por aquí tenemos un enlace doble y
también tenemos una cadena lateral
podemos empezar por contar los carbonos
y determinar cuál es la cadena de
carbonos más larga en esta molécula
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6
y si nos vamos de este lado tenemos 7 y
si nos vamos de este lado también
tenemos 7 así es que en realidad da
igual cuál de los dos caminos tomemos
tenemos 1
que tiene 7 carbono y tenemos que tomar
en cuenta que tiene un doble enlace
ahora esto de los dobles enlaces tiene
prioridad sobre cualquiera de los otros
grupos funcionales bueno en realidad no
sobre cualquier otro grupo funcional más
adelante vamos a ver otros grupos
funcionales que tienen prioridad sobre
los enlaces dobles pero los dobles
enlaces si tienen prioridad sobre
cualquier otro grupo funcional de esta
molécula o sea que tienen prioridad
sobre las cadenas laterales entonces
empezamos a enumerar los carbonos por el
extremo más cercano al enlace doble que
bueno en este caso realmente no
importaba cuál tenía mayor prioridad
porque los dos empezarían a numerar los
carbonos por aquí entonces este es el
carbono 1 carbono 2 carbono 3 carbono 4
carbono 5 carbono 6 y carbono 7 así es
que estamos lidiando con un
de que tienen 7 carbonos y luego 11 de
que tiene un enlace doble este enlace
doble que está entre el carbono 2 y el
carbono 3
entonces ponemos por aquí yo 2,3 no no
no espera me estoy equivocando
horriblemente porque únicamente tenemos
que poner el carbono más chico en el
cual empieza el enlace doble aunque
entonces tenemos aquí
efe 2 en o si no lo que estaba yo
diciendo poniendo hay una coma y un 3 es
que hay otro enlace doble por aquí que
empieza en el carbono 3 pero esto no es
lo que está sucediendo nunca y entonces
tenemos aquí el epp 12 no pero también
tenemos que decir que tenemos por aquí
una cadena lateral un grupo metilo que
empieza en el segundo carbono
así es que esto de aquí es un 2 metil
efe 2 en 2 porque está empezando en el
carbono 2 y metil porque este es un
grupo metilo entonces vamos a ver otros
ejemplos
tenemos un ciclo como siempre para
empezar a nombrar a esta molécula
empezamos con la cadena más larga de
carbonos y aquí tenemos 1 2
456 carbonos entonces estamos viviendo
con un
pero esta cadena de carbonos además está
formando un ciclo así es que tenemos que
llamarle si no además tiene un enlace
doble este enlace doble entonces va a
ser un ciclo hex
no ahora aquí seguramente tú puedes
decir y sal porque no tenemos que decir
en qué número de carbono está el doble
enlace como lo estábamos haciendo en los
otros dos ejemplos eso se debe a que
cuando tenemos un ciclo podemos empezar
a enumerar los carbonos justo en donde
empieza el doble enlace si por ejemplo
si no tuviéramos ninguno de estos otros
grupos
tendríamos simplemente un ciclo externo
ok a ver voy a dibujar por aquí el ciclo
externo
esto tal cual es el ciclo 'escena y
realmente no tenemos que poner en donde
empieza el enlace doble porque podemos
empezar diciendo que este es el carbono
1 y este es el carbono 2 y siempre que
tengamos un doble enlace va a ser el 1
ciclo exc no ahora por aquí todavía nos
falta nombrar todos estos grupos met y
los que tenemos por aquí que son
simplemente un carbono con otros tres
hidrógenos ok tenemos tres grupos metilo
así es que esta es una molécula
y metil ciclo externo pero aquí sí
tenemos que poner en qué carbonos están
estos grupos metidos y para eso tenemos
que enumerar a los carbonos pero de tal
forma que el enlace doble esté entre el
carbono 1 y el carbón o vox
entonces esto es el carbono 3 4 5 y 6 y
esto lo que nos dice es que tenemos un
grupo metil en el carbono 1 en el
carbono 4 y en el carbono
y es que esta molécula es un nuevo 46
primer ciclo externo
bueno espero que te haya parecido
interesante